it's arguably the most popular film of
several past generations Star Wars what
can you say about franchise as huge as
this well I could say I was introduced
to it by tu walks yep
the Ewoks cartoon is what got me into
watching these movies actually even
that's not even true the Ewoks cartoon
got me to watching the Ewoks movies that
went to TV then that got me to watching
the actual movies the reason I bring
this up is that I didn't really have
much hype for it nobody said this is a
cinematic masterpiece it's one of the
greatest movies ever made it's
phenomenal granted I did see images from
it all over the place but for the most
part I discovered it myself and like a
lot of people I not only greatly enjoyed
it but found great value in just how
many levels that entertained on kids
could watch it adults could watch it you
could tune in for the action or read
into the symbols admire how new it is
but also cheerfully paying homage to
laugh and cheer while also analyzing
what a very detailed mythos it is the
story as I am assuming most of you know
is about an evil empire that's taken
over the galaxy and wants to finish off
the last of the rebellion a rebel spy
named Princess Leia hype the plans to
destroy their newest weapon called the
Death Star with two droids named r2d2
and c3po they come across a farm boy
named Luke and a magical hermit named
obi-wan they realize they have to get
these plans to the rebels so they come
across a pilot named han Solo and
Chewbacca on their way they get snagged
by the evil empire led by the sinister
Darth Vader and end up trying to rescue
the princess while also destroying the
evil weapon before it destroys them okay
so what can I say about this film that
everybody hasn't said before well for
one it's not perfect which I know
doesn't sound shocking nowadays but for
time before the Internet how is
something you almost never said
everybody loves Star Wars and thought
frame-by-frame was just the ultimate
masterwork but as much as I love it
you've gotta admit some of its pretty
corny actually a lot of it but in the
best way the acting at times can be a
little hokey remember Princess Leia's
weird British accent or Luke's ear
grating ly whiny voice or solos constant
complaining yeah watch it again and tell
me you don't pick up on some of this on
top of that some of the dialogue can be
like when leia tells the villains she
should've noticed their foul stench when
she was brought on board
snap there's also a billion plot threads
that don't make sense but I kind of let
those go because it's fantasy and that's
never what the focus of fantasy really
is the magic doesn't lie in the details
but in how many different ways that can
speak to you as well as several
generations and that's what Star Wars
does really well as cliched and hokey
some of these characters can be we all
relate to them the wide-eyed Luke
Skywalker the cynical Han Solo the wise
master teacher the villain with a past
it really is clever and how much it
takes from certain stories from fairy
tales to folklore to Kurosawa to Stanley
Kubrick and even Flash Gordon in fact a
lot from Flash Gordon throwing the
special effects of 2001 but mixed with
the pacing of Seiya James Bond movie at
the time and you have something that was
very unique it explains all the areas
you want to know about and keeps vague
the areas you don't want to know about
the force is a perfect example of that
it's the magic energy that flows through
us all that can help people if they know
how to use it that can be anything it
can be religion it can be how ISM it can
be the power of God it can be the power
of the mind there's so many ways you can
interpret it the beauty of the film is
in its simplicity but with that said
there is a lot of detail in the
techniques the effects at the time were
groundbreaking and done for not a very
big budget it just took a lot of time
energy and devotion as well as pretty
good actors interacting often for as
simple as these archetypes are and yeah
sometimes as awkward as they can be
you still connect with them very quickly
we don't know much about Darth Vader yet
but by god James Earl Jones voice gives
him such a history you can tell this is
a guy who means business because he's
been through a lot and all of that just
comes through the voice and the
seriousness that everybody takes this
dialogue that a lot of other people will
kind of see a silly
as a surprising credibility to this
world a world that creates an
environment that both seems very simple
but somehow complex at the same time
sure it's silly but it's endearing and
puts a lot of thought in the areas that
you want to put a lot of thought into as
a lot of good myths do is it one of the
great myths I don't know if I can go
that
Pharr I'd still say probably check out a
lot of traditional ones to get an idea
of what great storytelling is but for
the film industry at the time and even
you could kind of argue today you don't
really see that many myths at least not
new ones and that one that captures so
many of the important elements so
creatively and with such fun
yeah I know I guess I'm saying what
everybody says about this movie but I
can't help it it's good I really enjoyed
it as a kid and I really enjoyed now
okay I can't quite join the group and
say it's one of the greatest things I've
ever seen but it has definitely left an
impact on me and for the right reasons
for me it was a gateway to other myths
an introduction to simple storytelling
that can lead to vast worlds and I
appreciate a great way for that I see
its flaws but the stuff that's good it's
just too clever to overlook I don't know
if it's the stroke of a creative artist
or a jumbled mess that accidentally
turned out something great but it's a
lot of fun to both watch and analyze I
can see why they show it in film classes
and analyze it here and there is it
overplayed sure do we praise it too much
probably but it's a great starting point
for opening up to more great stories so
grab your lifesaver get into your x-wing
and then force be with